le premier ministre a présidé cette
après midi une nouvelle réunion
interministérielle sur la sécurité
sociale cette séance de travail devrait
en principe être la dernière à matignon
avant le conseil des ministres de
mercredi qui prendra des mesures
destinées à résorber le déficit de la
sécurité sociale et commettent au point
monsieur jacques barrot le nouveau
ministre de la santé et de la sécurité
sociale le déficit de 7,6 tient
essentiellement un accroissement de
dépenses de santé qu'ils ont presque le
double de notre croissance économique
regardez ses courbes tout le problème de
la sécurité sociale est là en bas la
courbe de production de notre économie
c'est le fameux gâteau qu'il faut se
partager en disant ils augmentaient en
francs courants de près de 13% par an
mais dans le même temps les dépenses de
santé sans l'hôpital et c'est le
deuxième courbe augmentaient de plus de
15% par an alors que les dépenses
hospitalières
s'envolaient au rythme fou de 22 7%
chaque année ce taux de croissance
extrêmement fort dépenses sociales se
traduira en fin d'année par un déficit
de 3 milliards de francs mais il s'agit
là d'un déficit en terme comptable car
en réalité ce sont près de 10 milliards
de francs qu'il faudra trouver pour
mettre à l'aise la trésorerie de la
sécurité sociale alors comment faire
pour résorber un déficit il n'y a que
deux méthodes freiner les dépenses
augmenter les recettes freiner les
dépenses vous savez l'un des objectifs
du gouvernement et le premier ministre
récemment la rappeler seulement cela ne
peut pas avoir d'effet immédiat il reste
donc à augmenter les recettes est parmi
les hypothèses qui circulent le plus
actuellement on retient celle d'une
cotisation exceptionnelle qui pourrait
prendre la forme d'une double cotisation
sur un mois données de l'année mais ces
mesures ne s'arrêterait pas là de plus
en plus on souligne qu'il est aberrant
d'avoir d'un côté des recettes payée par
tout le monde et de l'autre des dépenses
ordonné par une profession libérale qui
par définition n'est soumise à aucun
contrôle il n'est donc pas exclu que
dans le dispositif qui sera annoncé
mercredi certaines mesures
contraignantes soient prises envers les
médecins